Let's go next to our caller from the two eight
one area code.
Who's calling today from two eight one
okay.
Hello?
Yes, that's you.
Who's this?
Oh, hi.
This is Raja.
I'm from Texas to be specific.
Uh, yeah, I've got two questions.
I've been a member for two years now.
So keep, keep fighting.
Good.
Um, the first question is, is it worth bringing
up the democratic primary during our Thanksgiving
holidays
because that's our role and
stuff.
Cause I mean like it and the thing that I
really want to, cause you know, I really only
ha had a chance to look at the most recent
climate report from the ICC that they released
last year and it's just so alarming what's
going to happen, you know, even with the warming
that we're already projected to have that,
you know, for me it seems like any, anytime
like there's only two candidates in my mind
that are even legitimately addressing climate
change or the urgency and maybe only one,
arguably we want to think about Bernie's plan.
Um, and so I don't know, like most of my family
are well off suburban, I guess, you know,
elite liberals or whatever.
Not really just upper middle income, but I
don't think they don't have the same urgency
that I do when it comes to this election.
So that was going to be my question.
My first question was going to be, are you
thinking about bringing up the democratic
primary to Republicans or to people on the
left who simply may or may not have decided
or maybe going the wrong way in the primary?
I, if you're talking here about, yeah, yeah.
If you're talking about a liberal leaning
family, I probably would bring up that, well,
what state is this in, by the way?
Uh, Texas, but uh, suburbs of Austin actually.
Okay.
So yeah, I didn't know if you were traveling
for Thanksgiving or if it's happening there.
Here I would bring it up.
I mean, you know, you want to bring it up
in a way that reflects the degree to which
you're willing to make people uncomfortable
or to start arguments.
And it's totally reasonable not to want to
do that at Thanksgiving.
But I would bring it up and I would gauge
w who are people voting for in Texas is an
important state in terms of delegates in the
democratic primary.
So yes, I would bring it up.
But you know, don't, you don't necessarily
need to be accusatory or attacking people,
but you can simply ask questions like if it,
you know, do you care?
They say I'm voting for Biden or whatever.
Okay, well are you concerned about the situation
with the climate?
If they say yes, then you say, Oh, what is
it that Biden plans to do?
And then hopefully they will then realize,
Oh actually I don't know if Biden's planning
to do anything.
Did you see what Bernie's plan is on this?
And maybe you can stimulate some thought in
that way.
Well, well that's the problem I think for
people that are generally doing okay in life,
the moment that you say I'm with Bernie, you
know, I, cause I'm, I'm younger than all of
them.
Right?
They're all older, educated professionals,
have jobs, all that stuff.
I'm, I'm still in college.
Um, so the problem ends up becoming that,
Oh, I'm with Bernie.
Well you're an extremist.
You know, like, you know, like you automatically
get put into like, you get boxed in and your
arguments are sort of brushed off just because
you're labeled, right.
Rather than, you know, taking a objective
look at the issue and trying to understand
what is the most, you know, actual tasks that
we need to take.
Well, listen, if you're called an ex, you
can't go point counterpoint on everything,
but if you're called an extremist for supporting
Bernie, I would encourage you to say, uh,
are are Denmark, Sweden, Switzerland, Norway.
You know what, I give the full list.
Are those countries extreme?
Because Bernie is not advocating for anything
more extreme than that.
Listen, I wish you good luck and hope.
I hope you don't make any, any enemies at
Thanksgiving.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
I do have a second question though.
Um, w part of the problem I think with arguing
for Bernie is people don't perceive him to
be as electable, quote, unquote, which is
honestly to me, the, just a completely speculative
concept of electability.
But, um, but I do have a doubt in my mind
about, let's say Bernie were to win the nomination.
The only thing that I think I see stopping
him is all the special interests will line
up and just pour mountains of money into the
election.
Um, because he's such a fundamental threat
to the way things are.
Do you see that as a possibility that he may
lose the election just viewed a special interest?
Um, you know, pouring all their money into
the election cycle?
It's certainly possible, but I think it's
just as likely or almost just as likely to
happen with Elizabeth Warren and I see them
as really the front runner, progressive contenders.
So, you know, unless you're saying, let's
just go with Biden because the special interests
will be less against him.
If we want a progressive that will, that money
will come out against Bernie.
That money will also come out against Elizabeth
Warren.
So I think we're just going to have to fight
that and beat it is the only way around it.
Listen, I appreciate the call I've got to
run because I've got a bunch of people that
want to get in here.
Before we go on Thanksgiving break,